ROSE HUBER: Welcome
from Dublin, Ireland.
We are here from day one of the
Princeton-Fung Global Forum.
My name is Rose Huber, from
the Woodrow Wilson School,
and I'm here with four wonderful
students from Princeton.
So not to put you guys on the
spot, but I do want to ask,
did you have a particular panel
that really interested you
today from what we saw?
And you kind of touched
on history a little bit,
but was there a panel
that really stuck out,
or person on a panel
that you thought, wow,
I really need to
connect with that person
tonight and talk to them?
Do you have any
reactions to that?
SUBJECT 1: I think
the obvious one for me
that was like star
for me was Margaret
Chan, the Director-General of the WHO.
So it was very cool to
hear her perspective,
and also contrasting it, how
she was very much involved
in the SARS epidemic--
or the outbreak--
and then being
involved in Ebola
and also being asked
very tough questions.
And so, it was cool because
my thesis adviser, Professor
João Biehl, was also here,
and then to see him go up
and ask her questions and
to see the interaction
between academia,
people who are handling
these issues in the real world.
Also, just at dinner,
I was sitting next
to a journalist at
NPR, so just seeing
all these different
worlds interact was great.
ROSE HUBER: So we went on
a walking tour of Dublin
yesterday, so what
are your impressions
of Dublin, and
just the conference in general?
You've kind of already
shared, but what
do you think about being
here at this conference?
Is it your first Fung
Forum conference?
Is it your first
time in Ireland?
SUBJECT 2: Very beautiful city.
The walking tour is great.
We got to see a lot of the
historical sights of Dublin.
We saw the castle.
We saw Trinity
College, very nice.
SUBJECT 3: It's really
warm and sunny here,
which I think people
are surprised about.
Everyone's surprised
that the weather's nice.
Apparently it's usually
really dreary and rainy here.
ROSE HUBER: Everybody thought
it would be rainy and cold.
SUBJECT 3: Yeah, it's
been a pleasant time.
SUBJECT 2: I read in
the New York Times
that apparently there's like
an unseasonal amount of fog
right now in Europe?
ROSE HUBER: Yeah.
SUBJECT 4: We did learn
on the walking tour
that the largest Viking
historical-- I guess-- dig up
is right here in Dublin,
so that was cool.
There's a picture
on Instagram of all
of us laying in the
Viking beds, ten across
on each side of the home.
So we checked that out.
ROSE HUBER: So any last
reflections before we close up.
We need to get
back to our dinner,
but we wanted to say hi
to everybody back home.
We miss you.
We're having a great time.
Any other thoughts
before we close out?
SUBJECT 4: I was going to answer
your question a little bit
before.
I really enjoyed
Elizabeth Levine,
who was from the CDC
and working
on the ground during the
politics session.
I think it was the
second section.
ROSE HUBER: The science,
yeah, science session.
SUBJECT 4: I'm sorry.
At science and plagues session; politics is tomorrow.
Yeah, so she was
super interesting,
and I think that, for me, that
was definitely the highlight
of the event so far.
ROSE HUBER: Yeah, a lot
of on-the-ground kind
of stories that we're getting
to hear at this conference,
which is really great, paired
with some academic discussions.
It's really a nice mix of
academics, people in the field.
So we have more tomorrow, more
anthropologists tomorrow, which
we're all looking forward to.
So goodnight from Dublin,
or good afternoon to you,
and thanks so much
for joining us.
SUBJECT 3: See you.
ROSE HUBER: Bye.